DANIELLE BUCKLEY: Hey,
welcome, everybody.
Good morning.
Thanks, all of you,
for making it here.
I'm Danielle Buckley.
I'm the Lead Product
Manager for Google+.
I want to start our
first session today just
by acknowledging and thanking
those of you in the room who
already use Google+ in
your organizations today.
Show of hands, who already uses?
Oh, that's great to see.
Awesome.
Thank you, guys.
You've all shown us,
through your experience,
the power of Google+ to
transform company culture,
to unlock innovation, and to
foster communications across
organizational boundaries.
You've all also provided us with
valuable feedback on things we
can do to make Google+ work even
better for your organizations.
Thank you.
We appreciate you and
everything you do.
And we're looking forward to
continuing to work with you.
Today, we'll talk about how
we're taking your feedback,
and building the next generation
of Google+ for the enterprise.
We'll spend the next
hour together focused
on three things.
First, I'm going to talk a
little bit about the ways that
companies are using
Google+ today to transform
their company cultures.
Then-- and for the
first time ever--
I'm truly excited to be able to
tell you about the 2017 roadmap
for Google+, what
we've got planned,
and the features that
we're going to be launching
specifically targeted
at enterprises.
And then finally, we'll close
our session with a panel
discussion and Q&A where a few
of our customers have kindly
agreed to come and talk about
their experiences using Google+
in their companies.
Over the last few months,
I've had the privilege
of having a number
of discussions
with businesses about what's
keeping them up at night.
And across industries,
between departments,
and across geographies,
there is one concern that
comes up time and time again.
How can I make sure that
my company is delivering
innovation, that we
stay ahead of the curve,
that we're getting the
most out of our employees?
In short, how can
I drive innovation?
At Google, we've seen
that innovation happens
when you bring people together.
That when you break down
boundaries, and barriers,
and make it easy for people to
share ideas, exciting things
happen.
On the Google+ Team, our aim
is to help you drive innovation
by connecting your company,
connecting your people,
their ideas, their
interests, their insights.
This means making
it easy for people
to connect in
different locations
to share best practices,
for leadership
to be able to take
the company's pulse,
and to keep people in the
loop, and for everyone
at every level of your
organization to stay connected,
and to feel like they're
truly part of a team.
With companies more and more
dealing with teams spread out
across the world, employees
who spend most of their time
in the field, large workforces
where it's not always
easy to know what's going
on, or who the experts are,
this can really be a challenge.
We believe that Google+ is
uniquely positioned to help.
And we hear this repeated by
those of you who have already
adopted Google+ in
your organizations.
So we hear things like this.
"We would never have achieved
this level of communication
and collaboration
without Google+."
"Google+ breaks down the
invisible walls between
disparate departments, and
creates new connections."
"Google+ connects us
like never before.
Now we can share expertise,
build relationships."
This is what gets us going.
This is what brings us
in to work every morning.
That's what gets us excited.
And there are three main ways
that we believe Google+ can
help connect your company
and drive innovation--
encouraging knowledge
sharing, engaging employees,
and facilitating
secure communication.
First and foremost, our
job is to facilitate
knowledge sharing.
We do this with tools that allow
teams to better communicate
internally, and smarts
that automatically
uncover untapped knowledge
from across your organization.
This is knowledge
sharing that breaks down
organizational silos, and
connects across geographies.
Second, you know that
more engaged employees
produce better work output.
You tell us this all the time.
And Google+ provides a really
easy and scalable channel
for employee engagement
across your organization,
letting everybody get involved.
Finally, we hear loud
and clear the importance
of secure communication
within and between teams.
And this is, of course, a
theme that you'll be hearing
throughout the week this week.
With robust sharing controls,
and dedicated spaces
for private discussions, Google+
provides a reliable, secure,
and scalable channel for your
organization to communicate.
With these three
pillars in mind,
I'm going to touch briefly on
some of the most widely-used
features of Google+
in the enterprise,
and talk a little bit about
how companies are using those
features today.
I'll start off with what's one
of the most widely used tools
in Google+, and something
that's really near and dear
to my heart, which
is Communities.
Communities and Google+ allow
groups of employees to come
together in a dedicated place to
talk about something specific.
So those of you who are using
Google+ already probably
already know this, right?
Communities can be locked
down to just your company.
They can be locked down to
just specific teams or groups
of people, and made
private, so that you
can have really secure,
confidential conversations
in them.
We've had lots of
inspiring stories
that come in about companies
using Communities to transform
the way their teams and
their companies work,
from collaborating on a
team, to allowing employees
to organize social groups,
to sharing customer stories.
One of the most interesting
customer examples
that I've heard
about Communities
comes from a global bank.
So this bank was
really struggling with,
how do we find out about
maintenance issues at our ATMs?
How do we make sure that
we're deploying people
to go fix them?
And the thing that they latched
on to as a potential solution
for this was, we've actually got
a whole ton of branch employees
who are already distributed
all across the globe.
What if we could
leverage those employees?
So what they did was they
enrolled all of their branch
employees into a large
community-- so 30,000 employees
in a community.
And all of them were then
transformed into, essentially,
ATM mystery shoppers.
So they were able to take
pictures, and make posts,
and file complaints when they
noticed issues in the field.
That then allowed
maintenance personnel
to go out and
address those issues.
Problem solved.
Of course, we also rely on
Communities at Google, as well.
So teams will often
have Communities
for their own internal
discussion talked about,
hey, what features
should we be developing?
What are you hearing
from customers?
How are we addressing
this particular concerns--
really get discussion
going on specific teams.
Then there's folks who
serve Google broadly, right?
The Google Travel
Team is a team that
helps Googlers who are
traveling around the globe
to visit other
offices or customers.
They've got a community
where anyone, any Googler,
can ask a question, hey,
what do I do about customs?
Or does anybody know how to
get a visa to this place?
I've got a surprise
trip coming up.
And then other Googlers are
able to answer their questions
really quickly.
It allows for a much
more scalable solution
to serving their needs.
One thing close to my
heart, product managers
also have a
community, where we're
able to share tips, and tricks,
and how to do our job better.
Like, what's something
that works for you?
I'm having this issue.
How would you guys approach it?
And we're able to really
easily communicate,
even though product
managers tend
to be distributed one in one
team, one in another team.
And so it can,
potentially, be very
difficult to share
knowledge and best practices
across that kind of
a distributed group.
So that's Communities.
Another tool we offer to
facilitate knowledge sharing
is what's called Collections.
Those of you who have used
Google+ in the past couple
of years probably noticed
the addition of this.
Collections are
individual streams.
So a particular employee
can create a collection
about a specific topic,
sort of like micro blogs.
And they allow folks
to focus their message
on a specific topic.
So for example, one
customer executive
uses a collection
to share things
that he's hearing
about industry trends,
and get them out to the whole
company in a lightweight way
that doesn't require
him to email everybody,
but in a way that
facilitates sharing.
At Google, we've got
a developer advocate
who started a collection called
HGRW, How Google Really Works.
How does Google really work?
Well, he finds posts that
other people are making--
here's how we do this
in this part of Google.
Here's how we develop
product over here.
Here's how we're
developing these concerns.
And really, by sharing this
into a single collection,
he's brought together a
whole bunch of knowledge
from across Google about what
makes our culture unique.
At a higher level, when
you look at all of this,
and bring it all together,
Google+ provides a window
for executives to understand
employee sentiment.
So one of the things
that can be hard
when you're in headquarters
is figuring out,
what's really going
on with my employees?
How are they really feeling?
So for example, you could
monitor employee chatter
in Communities, figure out
what are their real concerns,
potentially highlight
specific needs for improvement
in your organization.
Leaders can take advantage
of features like polls
to test ideas.
You know, we're thinking about
marketing this new product.
We've got a few names.
What do you guys
think about this?
And to get a sense of employees
reactions to suggestions.
For example, there
was an airline
who was finding it really
pretty difficult to connect
with their employees
who are on flight crews,
or out in the field
in operations.
These folks are on the
go all across the globe,
really difficult to talk
to all of them at once.
And so they set up global
and regional communities
where the CEO and other leaders
were able to post messages
that they were able to get to
everybody all across the globe,
and interact with their
employees on the go
since they had the mobile apps.
And then the corporate
communications team
is able to see things
that people shared
into that community and
gauge their response,
and kind of keep their finger
on the pulse of what's happening
in their organization.
Finally, the home
stream and notifications
ensure that employees don't
miss out on important messages,
regardless of where in
the company they are.
So these actions, as you know
if you already use Google+,
include updates from things
that they're already following,
as well as smart suggestions for
things across the company that
they should be aware of, but
aren't necessarily following
yet.
For example, many executives
at Google post publicly--
restricted to
google.com, of course--
when they want to
communicate with their teams.
And this gives them a
channel to communicate
on a range of subjects that
they wouldn't necessarily
want to send a full,
heavyweight email on.
The ability for these posts
to show up in the home stream,
and to notifications,
means that they're
able to communicate really
directly with a lot of people.
I want to change
gears, momentarily,
to talk about 2016 for Google+
because we had a really
exciting year.
Last year, among a
number of enhancements,
we launched three major things.
And I'm missing something
on here-- ah, great.
The most important
one was missing.
Big milestone for us-- we
launched Google+ as a G Suite
core service last August.
And we were privileged
and excited to join
the ranks of products
like Calendar and Gmail
that are well-used and loved by
our enterprises-- very exciting
for us.
We also rolled out the
new Google+ web UI to all
of our users, including
enterprise customers,
as well as consumers.
This new web UI moves really
seamlessly from desktop
to mobile--
really great for
employees on the go.
It also puts
knowledge-sharing, specifically
through Communities and through
Collections, front and center
to help companies make sure
that the folks that need to be
in the know stay in the know.
Finally, we made
significant improvements
to community moderation.
So this was a set of tools that
enabled community moderators
to take the reins of content
coming into their Communities.
This including things
like the ability
to approve every post that
comes into your community
before it shows up--
really good for
Communities where
you want to lock
down the message,
or to individually
white-list users.
You may have a set of users who
you know are great, and should
be posting into the
community, and another
set who you know you want to
review them a little more.
So we're excited to have this
enhanced suite of community
moderation tools.
All that said, we firmly believe
that this is just the beginning
for Google+.
You guys have all given
us lots of feedback.
And we've used that feedback
to develop a roadmap
for the next year that focuses
on the needs of enterprises
like yours.
So for the first time ever, I'm
really excited to today be able
to talk about the
upcoming roadmap for 2017,
what we're going
to be launching,
specifically for
enterprises using Google+.
And then, at this
point, our lawyers
asked me to remind you
that, while we strive
to meet the timelines that
I'm going to talk about,
and to launch all
these features,
all this is subject to
change without notice--
fine print.
[LAUGHING]
Really, the lawyer
line gets a laugh.
This is when you know
you need better jokes.
[LAUGHING]
So first, I want to
talk about enhancements
to knowledge sharing.
So Google+ today already
provides the ability
for your employees to tap into
knowledge and expertise from
across your organization that
they wouldn't otherwise have
access to.
Over the next year,
we'll continue
to use Google smarts
to enhance our ability
to deliver world-class
connectedness and knowledge
sharing across your enterprise,
for example, by tailoring
recommended Collections and
Communities to the things that
are most important
in your company.
This investment in
implying Google smarts
to your organization will make
it even easier for employees
anywhere in your company to
find the content, communities,
and people that they should
be in touch with to be
at their most innovative.
And then let's talk about
employee engagement.
This can be sort of
a nebulous subject.
You all want
employee engagement.
But how do you actually know
if your employees are engaged,
or if they're
engaged on Google+?
It can be tough.
So we're excited to announce
that we're going to be
introducing, in
the admin console,
tools that directly allow
you to measure the engagement
of your employees on Google+.
These metrics will allow admins
to dig into overall activity
in your domain.
For example, how
many posts are there?
How many comments are there?
How many plus ones?
How many folks are active
on G+ on any given day?
Which Communities
have the most members?
We're also going
to give you access
to user-level statistics.
So who in my company
is really active here?
Who are the drivers?
Who are the opinion leaders?
And finally, down
the road, we'll
also introduce
community-level metrics,
so you can see engagement
in particular Communities.
Finally, let's talk a bit
about secure communication.
One thing we've heard
from many of you--
and especially those in
highly-regulated industries--
is the importance of being
able to track user activity
at a transaction level.
That's like the really
detailed stuff, right?
This year, will introduce an
enterprise log API that will
allow your company, or
an authorized partner,
to track Google+ activity of
specified users in your domain.
For example, you'll be
able to track in detail,
which post did a user make?
When did they edit them?
Which comments did they make?
When did they remove
or delete those?
Giving you full trail
of their activity.
This one I'm really
excited about.
In addition to being able
to track employee activity,
we know many of you would like
to have further control over
the extent to which your
employees are able to interact
with the outside
world on Google+.
We're excited to
announce that we're
in the process of developing new
admin settings that will allow
you to select the level
of openness that's
right for your company.
So for this, there are going
to be three levels of options.
The first level-- and this is
the current setting for all
domains using Google+--
is what we call public.
Public means that
all of your users
are able to freely interact
within your domain,
as well as outside
of your domain.
They, of course,
still have the ability
to control who they share
with, such that only people
within the domain can see it.
They can still lock
down Communities
to within just your domain.
But in addition,
they have the ability
to explore content shared
outside of their domain,
as well as to talk
to customers who
may be in the outside world, to
post on topics in which they're
thought leaders.
The second option-- and this is
where we get into what's new--
is a discovery mode.
So in this mode, users
can still see content
that's being posted externally.
So they're able
to see how people
are talking about your company.
They're able to see what people
are posting in your industry.
But they're restricted
from sharing or commenting
externally.
This option is potentially
useful for folks
who maybe shouldn't
have a public presence,
but still want to be able to
stay on top of what's happening
outside of your organization.
The final option is what
we call walled garden.
This is the most locked
down of the options.
And in this mode, users aren't
able to see external content
in recommendations, in
suggestions, in Google+ search.
And they, of course, aren't
able to post, or comment,
or plus one externally either.
Each of these options can be
customizable at an OU level.
So if you wanted your
marketing department
to be able to post
externally, but thought
that R&D would be better served
by a discovery mode setting,
that's going to be an option
that's available to you.
Finally, we've heard lots
of input from those of you
who would like the ability to
tighten down security, and be
sure of who's involved
in the conversation,
but who still want to be able to
collaborate with people outside
of your domain.
For example, you may want to
brainstorm potential ideas
with clients.
You may want to work
with partner teams.
You may want to talk to
employees in a sister company.
To allow you to do that
safely and securely, we're
introducing multi-domain
Communities.
So these are Communities
that are domain restricted.
But they're restricted
to multiple domains.
So you can have that
secure conversation,
be sure that things
aren't being leaked,
that people outside of the
domain aren't being invited.
But you're able to do that with
the companies that we know you
work with in your
day-to-day jobs--
so securely restricted,
but now collaborative too.
All right, I know what
you've been waiting for.
I said we're going
to tell you when
we were shipping this thing.
So I guess I should
actually do that.
So we'll start by introducing
domain-level user metrics
in Q2.
In Q3, things start
to really get real.
So you'll see
multi-domain Communities,
user-level usage metrics, and
the Google+ enterprise log API.
And then in Q4,
walled garden, which
gives you three settings
on domain openness,
is going to launch.
So it's an exciting year for us.
And we hope, an exciting
year for you, as well.
By helping you break down
barriers and share knowledge
across your company,
engage all your employees,
no matter their
level or location,
and providing secure
communications needed
to discuss new ideas, we believe
Google+ can help your company
come together and do
more innovative work.
And while I'm incredibly
excited about all
we've been able to
accomplish together already,
I'm even more excited
about what's to come.
Your partnership through
your trial, your feedback,
your drive to push to get even
better is helping us improve
Google+ and make it even
better serve your enterprises.
So thank you for that.
We're looking forward to
unlocking even more innovation
in your enterprises together.
And thanks, everybody,
for taking the time,
and choosing to come
here about Google+.